Bitte schön.
Guten Abend.
Ich stelle mich vor kurz.
Ich bin Dr. Kurt.
Der Dienst haben wir auf der Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Wenn Sie damit einbekommen sind.
Gerne.
Ich bräuchte ein paar Informationen über Sie, bevor wir anfangen.
Okay?
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Siegfried Neumann.
Siegfried.
Können Sie bitte vor und nach Nachnamen stabilisieren?
Nachnamen ist Neumann.
Nordpol, Emil, Ulrich, Marta, Anton, Nordpol, Nordpol.
Okay.
Und Vorname?
Siegfried, S-I-E, Gustav, Friedrich, Richard, Ina, Emil, Dora.
Okay.
Herr, Norm.
Siegfried, Siegfried, S-I-E, Gustav, Friedrich, Richard, Ina, Emil, Dora.
Okay.
Herr Neumann.
Okay, Herr Neumann.
Siegfried, alt und neu.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
32 Jahre alt.
Okay. Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 2.2.1990.
1990.
2.2.1990.
90 Jahre alt.
Okay, gut. Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 8 Jahre alt.
Ich bin 78 kg.
78 kg.
Gleich.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
1,75 m groß.
Okay.
Vielen Dank für alle Informationen.
Herr Neumann.
Welche Beschwerden führen Sie?
Was ist passiert?
Vor drei Wochen, am Wochenende,
habe ich Schmerzen im rechten Kniegelenk.
Ach so.
Okay.
Die Schmerzen schränken meinen Beweglichkeit an.
Ich kann nicht richtig mein Knie beugen.
Oder wenn ich beim Auto aussteige,
habe ich Schmerzen im rechten Knie.
Okay.
Hatte Sie einen Unfall vor drei Wochen?
Nein.
Ich habe einen Unfall vor drei Wochen.
Ich bin auch nicht beim Spiel gestürzt.
Während ich nach Hause gegangen bin,
hatte der Schmerz immer mehr zugenommen.
Ach so.
Können Sie sich an einen Auslöse erinnern?
Was ist mit dem Knie?
Ich bin nicht gestorben.
Ich habe meinen Knie nicht verdreht.
Obwohl ich mit meinem Spiel bin,
habe ich auch nicht verdreht.
Ich habe mir den Schmerz nicht verdreht.
Aber es ist noch mehr zu vorn.
Am nächsten Tag war noch mehr zu vorn.
Was ist mit dem Knie?
Wie genau können Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ich meine, ich finde da vorhanden.
Ja, das ist manchmal so ein Stechen der Schmerz, würde ich beschreiben,
aber auch ein dumpfer Schmerz.
Ich kann da nicht genau sagen, mit dem Finger wo, aber das ist an der
Innenseite des Kniegelenkens.
Innenseite.
Ja, und unter der Kniekehle, also innen und Kniekehlenbereich, da tut es mir weh.
Der Schmerz ist nicht dauernd, insbesondere bei Belastung.
Also wenn ich lange laufe oder wenn ich mich beuge, mein Knie mobilisiere,
also knier, also beugen.
Und da sind die Schmerzen so stichartig.
Haben Sie in Ruhe auch die Schmerzen oder nur bei der Belastung?
Nur habe ich ganz leichte Schmerzen, also minimal.
Okay, aber in Ruhe haben Sie auch?
Ja, in Ruhe habe ich ganz leichte, manchmal.
Also nicht dauernd.
Also seit drei Wochen habe ich die Schmerzen,
sondern einmal pocht das.
Okay, okay, das verstehe ich, ich verstehe.
Also wie stammt sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskalofon 1 bis 10?
Wie können Sie bewerten, die Schmerzintensität?
Ich würde mal sagen 4.
4, also das ist nicht so heftig, oder?
Genau, das ist nicht so heftig.
Okay, Sie brauchen keine Schmerzmittel oder so.
Nein, ich habe bei Bedarf von Freunden von mir eben Profen genommen.
Das hat abends immer mir geholfen.
Aber ich kann doch nicht so weiterleben, Herr Doktor.
Was habe ich denn?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Okay, aber Sie tun nicht laufen?
Ja, ich kann laufen.
Aber Sie haben einen Bewegungsanschränkung an der...
Bewegung, das kann ich beugen.
Beugen ist auch keine Bewegung.
Bei Beugen tut das, wenn ich maximal beuge, geht nicht mehr.
Auf einem Linkenknick kann ich maximal beugen,
und rechte Knien ist ein bisschen eingeschränkt.
Entgradig eingeschränkt.
Achso, okay, Sie haben also beide Knienprobleme?
Nein, ich wollte nur beschreiben.
Mein linkes Knien läuft gut.
Okay, ich verstehe also, bei der rechte Knien...
Es ist weniger.
Also kann man beugen und strecken,
aber rechtlich ist es nicht so gut bei dem Beugen wie mein linkes Knien.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion ausstrahlen?
Ich meine, also Kusssohle oder so?
Nein, ich würde sagen, das ist lokal.
Lokalisch, ja.
Haben Sie ein Taupayski-Fühl oder Krippen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nicht? Okay.
Ja, gut.
Und noch andere Beschwerden haben Sie, Herr Neumann?
Wie zum Beispiel haben Sie...
Entschuldigung, Neumann.
Neumann, okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Nein, eigentlich fühle ich mich gut.
Okay, gut, sehr gut.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihren Allgemeinzustand
einige Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Probleme, ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein, habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie Probleme bei einem Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, wird alles normal, wie immer.
Haben Sie Fieber, Herr Neumann?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Auch? Okay, sehr gut.
Sind bei Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, habe ich bis jetzt keine Schwindel.
Okay, okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie Abwechslossigkeit oder...?
Nein, alles gut.
Okay, gut.
Und hat sich Ihr Gewicht in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Gewicht, also nicht markant.
Okay, das ist unabhängig.
Sehr gut.
Okay, Herr Neumann.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihnen einige Fragen stellen,
um ein unversendetes Bild von Ihrer kranken Geschichte zu haben.
Okay, haben Sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Nicht dazu, also ich bin, denke ich, gesund.
Ja, Sie sind gesund, ja, richtig.
Also ich nehme keine Medikamente ein oder nicht,
dass ich etwas wüsste.
Ich bin freundlich, ich schwimme und spiele Tennis.
Okay, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Operiert worden, ja.
Das war mein 10. Lebensjahr, wo ich an Blindam operiert.
Blindam?
Ja.
Okay, okay.
Sind das Komplikationslos verlaufen oder...?
Ja, also meine Eltern sagen mir, ich hätte allergisch reagiert gegenüber Penezillin.
So, Penezillin?
Ich wusste mir Penezillin geben und da habe ich allergisch reagiert
und hätte ich reagiert und da, seitdem darf ich kein Penezillin mehr einnehmen.
Okay, ich verstehe ja, wie euch das allergiechiert, also was haben Sie?
Also man sagte mir, dass ich schlechte Luftnoten, also schlechte Atmen konnte, Luftnoten.
Okay, Luftnoten.
Ja.
Hätte ich gehabt, ja.
Okay, gut.
Und noch andere Operationen oder...?
Eigentlich nicht, bis aufs Blindam.
Okay, nur Blindam-Operation.
Okay, gut.
Ja, Neumann, nehmen Sie, also regelmäßig oder elegantlich,
medikamental?
Nein, nehme ich nichts.
Bis auf diese Ibuprofen, die ich jetzt ab und zu mal genommen habe,
nicht regelmäßig, dann nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Okay, gut.
Also Sie meinen nur Beiber-...
Beiber-Abschmerzen.
Ibuprofen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass ihr Freund damals Ihnen Ibuprofen geben.
Ja, genau.
Ja, welchen Sie wissen Sie?
Ja, das habe ich auch noch zu Hause, 600 mg.
600 mg.
Wie viel mal haben Sie eingenommen?
Ja, bis jetzt, vier, fünf Mal insgesamt habe ich eingenommen.
Aber das hilft, oder?
Ja, das hat die Schmerzen gelindert.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay, verstehe.
Okay, abgesehen von Ibuprofen nehmen Sie nicht andere Medikamente.
Nein, mein Freund, der hatte mir erst mal eine Dicklofen angegeben,
das habe ich nicht vertragert.
Dicklofen, wann?
Warum haben Sie eingenommen?
Weil ich habe die Schmerzen gehabt im Knie,
dann hat er gesagt, ich habe zwei Medikamente,
ich habe Medikamente,
da hat er erst mal Dicklofen angegeben,
da habe ich Bauchschmerzen gehabt, Durchfall.
Und dann hat er gesagt, hier, nehmen wir Ibuprofen,
vielleicht schlägt das dir, und das hat mir geholfen.
Okay, dann hat Ihr Freund Ihnen Ibuprofen gegeben.
Genau, danach.
Okay, ich verstehe, okay.
Ja, das heißt, Sie haben auch Dicklofen, Alergie, oder?
Ja, Alergie, weiß ich, also ich habe keinen Luftdruck gehabt.
Ich denke mal, ich habe es nicht vertragert.
Nach dem Einnahme haben Sie Luftdruck, oder?
Durchfall gehabt und Bauchschmerzen.
Durchfall und Bauchschmerzen, okay.
Okay, gut.
Okay, das ist alles, oder?
Ja, genau.
Gut, und so bisher haben Sie gesagt,
dass Sie Genesilien und Dicklofenack-Allergie haben.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergie?
Ich habe keine, wie zum Beispiel, Kontrast mit der, oder?
Nicht, dass ich rüste.
Oder um Verstehlekeit, nicht?
Nein, nicht, dass ich rüste.
Okay, gut, ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie rauchen, Herr Neumann.
Rauchen, ich rauche nicht.
Nicht?
Nein.
Sie haben nicht geraucht, davor, oder?
Ja, wo ich 20 Jahre alt war, hatte ich ein,
zwei Mal versucht, zu rauchen, aber ich habe nicht zu regeln,
das war einmal Versuch.
Aber eigentlich habe ich nicht gedacht.
Ich weiß doch nicht, ob ich das richtig eingezogen habe.
Okay, okay, das freut mich.
Das ist sehr gut, ja, Sie wissen,
der Zigaretten ist sehr gefährlich, Herr Neumann.
Ja.
Okay, gut, und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, eigentlich nicht abends, wenn so Geburtstag,
oder kann man so sagen, bei Gelegenheit,
wenn so Feier, Geburtstag, Fasching,
oder irgendwann schüßt, dann trinke ich mal Alkohol,
sonst trinke ich nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, was trinken Sie, bei Feiern oder so, wissen Sie?
Ja, was trinken Sie?
Bier oder Wein?
Ja, eher Bier.
Bier, ein Bier, okay, gut.
Keine Wein.
Also nächste Frage ist die Routinefrage, Herr Neumann.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder davor haben Sie konsumiert?
Oh, Drogen, nein.
Nein, nie.
Okay, sehr gut.
Also, was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Neumann?
Ja, ich bin Immobilienmakler.
Immobilienmakler.
Okay, gut.
Können Sie ein bisschen erklären, was machen Sie?
Was machen Sie, also Immobilienmakler?
Ja, wir haben eine Firma, wo ich heute ein Firmar verkaufen kann.
Okay, okay, Sie haben eine Firma,
Sie wissen eine Firma und Sie verkaufen Haus oder so?
Verkaufen, verkaufen, vermitteln.
Okay, okay, sehr gut.
Okay.
Wohnungen vermieten von einer Person und so weiter.
Immobilienmakler.
Okay, das versteht mich ja gut.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Neumann?
Ich bin nicht verheiratet, nein.
Nicht, okay, oder haben Sie eine feste?
Beziehung, ja, ich habe meine Freundin, mit der ich seit 6 Jahren zusammen bin.
Seit 6 Jahren, okay, sehr gut.
Wohnen Sie zusammen oder?
Ja, wir werden zusammen.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, wir haben keine Kinder.
Keine Kinder, okay, gut.
Ja, jetzt zu Familienamnese, Herr Neumann.
Leben Ihr Eltern noch?
Ja, mein Eltern leben.
Okay, sehr gut.
Also, sind Sie gesund, als ich meine Vater, Mutter oder Geschwister?
Ja, also, die scheinen gesund zu sein, aber mein Vater nimmt Medikamente wegen Bluthochdruckerkrankungen.
Bluthochdruckerkrankungen, okay, seit, wissen Sie seit wann?
Ich weiß, weiß ich nicht.
Okay, nur Bluthochdruck.
Okay, bei meinem Vater, so weit ich weiß, ich nehme nur Bluthochdruck, wenn ich kann sein.
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Okay, gut.
Und Ihr Mutter ist sie gesund?
Ja, relativ, die nimmt Medikamente ein wegen Zucker.
Zucker?
Zucker.
Und irgendein Medikament, ich weiß nicht wie es heißt, wegen ihrer Schildrüse.
Und Schildrüse.
Ja, aber wegen, weswegen?
Sehr flott, in zivilsten Methoden.
Also ein paar Schildrüsen Problem, aber zivilsten Methoden.
Ja, genau.
Der Funktionen oder ein Karzionomen, nicht.
Nein, nichts.
Okay, gut.
Und Herr Neumann, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Schwester?
Okay, ich habe die Schwester gesund?
Ja, genau, sie ist gesund.
Sehr gut.
Ja, gut, Herr Neumann, vielen Dank für alle Informationen.
Okay, und vorerst alle für mich wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Ja, jetzt möchte ich Ihnen erklären, wie wir weiter vorgehen wollen
und was wir noch untersuchen möchten.
Aber haben Sie irgendwelche Fragen, oder?
Fragen?
Ja, wie geht es denn weiter?
Was wird jetzt passiert?
Ja, ja, ich habe die Schwester.
Ja, Herr Neumann, bisher haben wir nur das Anamesegespräch,
das Aufnahmengespräch beendet.
Okay, und deshalb kann ich nicht zu viel sagen.
Ja, der Verdacht auf Knien,
Verletzung besteht bei Ihnen.
Ich meine, ja, Sie, vielleicht haben Sie sich eine Verletzung
beim Tennis spielen zu gesogen, aber ich kann nicht so richtig sagen,
um eine richtige Diagnose stellen zu können,
brauche ich einige Untersuchungen.
Ich habe eine körperliche Untersuchung und dann ein Bildgebendes,
Verfahren, ja, die Röntgenaufnahme oder gegebenenfalls MRT.
Okay?
Röntgen MRT, ist es gefährlich?
Ja, eigentlich nicht, das ist eine Verfahren,
deshalb brauchen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Frau Neumann, Röntgenaufnahme ist...
Herr Neumann.
Entschuldigung, Herr Neumann, Röntgenaufnahme ist nicht invasives,
also medizinische Verfahren, das ist Routine-Fahrung.
Und MRT ist auch nicht gefährlich,
nur so arbeitet mit Magnetfeld.
Ich meine nicht mit Röntgenstrahlen, verstehen Sie?
Ja.
Brauchen Sie keine Sorgen, aber vor der Untersuchung
müssen Sie ja mit der haltigen Geschenke absetzen.
Geschenke?
Metallhaltigen Schmuck oder so ein...
Also.
Schmuck oder so ein Abschiff, okay?
Sie haben ja also nicht nirgendes Problem,
oder nicht nirgendes Problem.
Nein, mit der Schüste.
Okay, das ist wichtig also.
Okay, das ist alles.
Okay, an was denken Sie als erstes Herr Doktor?
Sie müssen noch Untersuchungen machen, das habe ich gestanden.
Ja, ich mache...
Also denken Sie als erstes?
Ja.
Was ist Ihr Bauchgefühl?
Wievte?
Was sagt Ihr Bauchgefühl, was ich habe?
Bauchgefühl.
Was meinen Sie Bauchgefühl? Also Sie haben Bauchgefühl...
Kommt Ihnen rein, Bauchgefühl.
Wie ist Ihr Bauchgefühl, was ich für Erkrankungen habe?
Was meinen Sie?
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, Sie haben eine...
Verletzung, aber was denken Sie an einer Verletzung?
Also ich denke, minsküs rückgült...
Okay.
Ja, vor der Band, dahinter Band,
lesung sein, aber ja, das ist nur eine...
Wir wissen unsere Kukung.
Okay, danke, Sie haben es noch gehört.
Danke schön.
Nur eine Frage zur Sicherheit.
Sie zweiten, zweiten, 1990, 1990, Jahrhundert.
Ja, genau.
Okay, gut.
Vielen Dank für alle Informationen, Herr Neumann.
Danke, Herr Dr. Kurtz.
Okay.
Ich habe Fragen.
Ja.
Hatten Sie so etwas für Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine gerötet oder warm sind?
Nein, ist nicht gerötet, oder ist es nicht warm?
Hatten Sie als Kind häufig einzige Mann der Entzündung?
Oder hatten Sie als Kind romantisches Fieber?
Hatten mir meinen Eltern nicht gesagt, ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern.
Vielen Dank.
Nur eine Frage.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute gerne den 22-jährigen Patient, Herr Neumann vorstellen.
Wie alt?
32.
32-jährigen Patient, Herr Neumann vorstellen.
Er ist am 2.
2.
1999 geboren.
Er ist 78 kg schwer.
1990.
Ja, Boxer.
Okay, gut.
Ich weiß, dass ich 2-mal 99 geboren habe.
Okay.
Er ist 78 kg schwer.
Und ein Patient, der sich auf die Hand schlägt,
hat er 78 kg schwer und 1,75 m groß.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Herr Neumann, stellte sich heute wegen seit 3 Wochen bestehende
starke Schmerzen am rechten Kniegelenk bei uns vor.
Der Patient sei vor 3 Wochen beim Tennisspielen mit seinem Freund gewesen.
Der Patient hat eine Schmerz,
der Patient schmerzst,
an der Betroffene Stelle bemerkt.
Die Schmerz sei am Anfang noch nicht noch schlimmer,
aber im Laufe des Saits,
sei die Schmerzschlimma geworden.
Der Patient bewertete die Schmerzintensität auf eine Schmerzkala
von 1,4 m.
Der Patient klart auch leichte Schmerzen.
Der Patient konnte nicht
ihr rechten Kniegelenk
im Saich-Bewegungs-Einschränkung aufkefallen.
Gegen die Schmerzen,
der Patient, der Betroffene,
600 mg, 4,5 m eingenommen,
aber die Einnahme von Schmerzmitteln
habe nicht Linderung gebracht.
Die Frage nach Überkeit,
Insomnia,
Hinapäten, Gehwitzverlust,
wurde verneid.
Der Patient habe sich eine Epandektomie
mit 10 Jahren unterzogen.
Die Einnahme von Medikamenten an Amnesien
ergab die gelegentliche Einnahme über Profen.
Die Anzeige der Patientin
reagiert auf Pinseln,
die sich durch Atemnot veräußert.
Eine Diktofenekalergie
für Ushar bei ihm,
optimale Schmerzen und Diarrö.
Nikotin und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Der Patient trinkt gelegentlich
bei bestimmten Anlässen.
Der Patient sei immobile Makler,
habe keine Kinder, er sei leid.
Aber er habe seit 6 Jahren
eine feste Besicherung,
damit seine Freunde zusammen.
Seine Mutter leidet an Diabetes,
um zu verheiratet zu werden.
So wie ein Problem,
bei seinem Vater sei eine Artérie
und eine Vertunung bekannte.
Er habe eine Schwester,
die aktuell als Gehäuser war.
Ich habe die Anzeige von
Minisküs-Ruptua aus.
Das Diagnose der Transienten
kommt von
Distal-Tibia-Fractua
oder
Distal-Femua Distortion in Petraht.
Nach der
Erfolgen des
Vitalparameterübergrückung
und Labontersum
nach der
Vitalparameterübergrückung
und Körperlö
und Labontersum
mit der Bestimmung
von der kleinen Blutbild-Parameter
und
die Nieren- und Leber-Parameter
die Schichtdrüsen-Parameter
und
die Anschilis-Zolt-Röntgenaufnahme
und die MRT-Erfolgen.
Bei der Röntgenaufnahme,
wenn Sie eine Röntgenaufnahme anfordern,
Sie lassen eine
Röntgenaufnahme
von Patella
oder
in 2 Beinen
am rechten Knie
oder
Kniegelenk in 2 Ebenen.
Sie lassen eine Röntgenaufnahme
von Patella
oder Kniegelenk in 2 Ebenen.
Ich möchte nur ein fachberig Benussner.
Vielleicht in der Röntgenaufnahme,
wie kann man das beschreiben?
Also man kann generell
fast bei den orthopedischen
Sachen, bei vielen Sachen
immer in 2 Ebenen, dann ist es immer richtig.
Man kann auch in 2 Ebenen
eine Röntgenaufnahme anlassen.
Was wollen Sie mit den Röntgen
ausschließen?
Es kann ein Fraktur sein.
Bei der Röntgenaufnahme können wir
Fraktur beurteilen.
Aber bei diesem Fall
bestehe ich der Verdacht auf
Verletzung von Miniskuss.
Ist es die
Was würde man,
Was würde man aufnehmen, würden Sie machen, um ein Miniskuss
auszuschließen oder zu beweisen?
Miniskuss.
Am 1. würde ich gerne
eine Körperentwicklung machen.
Das ist ein bestimmtes
Zeichen für Miniskuss.
Das würde als
Lachmantest bezeichnen.
Zum Beispiel.
Nach der Körperentwicklung
können wir eine richtige Diagnose
können eine MRT durchführen.
Das ist wichtig, um
eine Weichtalorgane
noch besser beurteilen zu können.
Was würden Sie
machen?
Was haben Sie jetzt
mit dem Patient gemacht?
Was haben Sie jetzt gerade empfohlen?
Der wird ja noch geröntcht.
Nach der Untersuchung
wenn jemand andere hat
eine Miniskusslesion.
Wenn wir eine Miniskusslaptöre
verstellen, können wir
möglicherweise eine operative Therapie empfehlen.
Wir würden eine operative
Eingriff empfehlen.
Patient buralt
einiges Zeit.
Ich bin nicht mehr 4-6 Wochen
mit
Stütze laufen können.
Und
der Patient sollte auf
schwierige Sport
aufversetzen.
Immer oder für eine
operative Therapie.
Man braucht einiges Zeit
aber nach der Heilung
kann man auch normal leben.
Mit Physiotherapie zum Beispiel.
Natürlich.
Das ist krankengünstig.
Man kann das gelenkstabilisieren.
Durch die Muskulatur.
Haben Sie noch eine Frage?
Nein,
ich möchte von Ihnen.
Ansonsten gibt es keine
Erfrage.
Einmal
im Profen hatte der Patient gesagt,
er hat nicht gebracht, aber es hat eine Linderung gebracht.
Dann haben Sie es falsch gehört.
Bei
Diplofenac wollte ich daraus hinaus,
dass es auch Medikament-Unfertiglichkeit gibt.
Eine allergerische Reaktion,
wie Atemnot oder Hautausschlag,
hat er nicht gehabt.
Er hat eine Unverträglichkeit über Diplofenac gehabt.
Wir können nach der Symptome
auf der Diplofenac
beachten.
Das ist eine Unverträglichkeit.
Wenn der Patient sagt,
ich habe eine Hautausschlag,
dann sagen wir Diplofenac Allergie.
Aber in diesem Fall
müssen wir
Diplofenac Unverträglichkeit.
Sie haben aber
Penicillin und Diplofenac Allergie gesagt.
Ich habe mich gefragt,
ob ich normalerweise Diplofenac Allergie
und Diplofenac Allergie
habe.
Ich habe die Patientin gesagt,
dass sie die Hautausschmerzen hatten.
Deshalb müssen wir Diplofenac Unverträglichkeit.
Ich bin kein Internist, aber ich bin kein Internist.
Ich bin Karasseriearzt, also Kapurta-Doctorin.
Aber ich würde sagen,
die Patientin hat eine Artemnot.
Die Eltern haben gesagt,
die Eltern haben eine Artemnot.
Anscheinend hat er eine Angina.
Er hat eine Schwelmung des Halses gehabt.
Deswegen hat er eine Artemnot.
Die Eltern haben gesagt, ich habe eine Allergie.
Er ist 10 Jahre alt gewesen.
Er wusste nicht, was er hat.
Er wusste nicht,
ob er Diplofenac hatte.
ob er eine Cortison bekommen.
Er hatte nur Bauchschmerzen.
Er hatte eine Unverträglichkeit.
Ich wollte nur darauf hin,
dass man auch Medikamente-Unverträglichkeit hat.
Sie haben angeschnitten.
Ich möchte nur fragen,
ob die Diplofenac mit Bauchschmerzen durchfallen.
Deshalb sollten wir Diplofenac...
Ich denke, man müsste noch mal einen Internist fragen.
Aber ich würde sagen, ja.
Er hat es nicht gut vertragen.
Warum?
Das kann immer noch eine leichte Allergie sein.
Da muss man einen Allergie-Test machen.
Aber ich würde fragen,
meine Absicht war,
dass ich...
Dann haben Sie zum Beispiel weiter oben als Vorstellung gesagt,
die Mutter habe eine Schildrüsenerkrankung.
Nein, Schildrüsenproblem haben Sie gesagt.
Ich würde nicht Problem sagen,
sondern eine Schildrüsenerkrankung.
Nicht Problem, sondern Erkrankung.
Das ist Kleinigkeit, weiß ich gerade.
Dann wollte ich nur noch hinweisen.
Bewegungsein schenken.
Wenn ich beim Elebogen leicht nicht bewegen kann,
ist auch eine Bewegungsein schenken.
Oder wenn ich entgradig nur ein bisschen nicht ganz beugen kann,
Eine Bewegungsein schenken heißt nicht,
dass man nicht beugen kann, sondern dass es eingeschränkt ist.
Das ist eine Frage,
dass man nicht beugen kann,
dass man nicht beugen kann.
Das hat gesagt,
dass man bei maximaler Bewegung kann,
dass man nicht beugen kann.
Aber die Bewegungsein schenken.
Genau, generell.
Nur eine Information.
Bei maximaler Bewegung zum Beispiel.
Kann man so sagen.
Aber ansonsten hat er keinen.
Bei maximaler Bewegung.
Oder der hat ja gesagt,
dass er beim Auto aussteigen muss.
Das heißt, beim Auto aussteigen muss man eine Distortionübung machen.
Das heißt, es gibt auch so Hinweise,
dass es vielleicht ein Miniskus sein könnte.
Aber bei maximaler Bewegung ist es auch nicht komplett.
Ja, nicht komplett.
Und bei in diesem Fall auch so nicht komplett.
Ja, genau.
Aber eine maximale Bewegungsein schenken wäre,
ich kann nicht beugen.
Eine maximale Bewegungsein schenken.
Ich kann nichts machen.
Es gibt eine Papierbegriffe dafür.
Das ist komplett.
Anhand des Zusatzes,
ob Entgradig Bewegungsein schenken.
Entgradig heißt dann zum Beispiel HWS Rotation.
Wenn ich normalerweise 80, 90 Grad machen kann,
reden nach rechts, nach links.
Und nach rechts nur 30 Grad machen kann,
dann sage ich dann, der hat eine Rotationseinstreckung,
der hat eine halbe Söhne nach rechts.
Dann kann man dann auch eine Bewegungsein schenken.
Oder komplett Bewegungsein schenken.
Man kann auch komplett Bewegungsein schenken,
das heißt, man kann gar nichts beugen.
Mein Kind kann nicht bewegen, komplett einschränken.
Vorhin war das nur eine Entgradig Bewegungsein schenken.
Bei Herrn Neumann.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie,
Sie sind heute glaube ich zum ersten Mal da.
Ich versuche, Sie haben, also nach meiner Meinung,
Sie haben ein sehr sicheres Auftreten, das ist gut.
Sie beherrschen die Sprache gut, denke ich, nach meiner Meinung.
Ich bin kein Deutschlehrer, also grammatikalisch,
kann man bestimmt einige Sachen sagen,
Sie haben zum Beispiel ein paar Wörter manchmal weggelassen,
sozusagen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, welche.
Genal man hat ein Konusiusnis,